We call this meme generating app MeMe.
MeMe let's you choose
an image from your phone.
Here I've got some funny
ones of my teammates,
like this one of Jared in the library.
So I'm going to make a meme
that makes fun of napping and
API's because he's working
on a networking course.
And then once you've added text to an
image, you can share it with a friend.
MeMe stores the memes you've made in
a collection of meme model objects.
And you can browse your
memes in a table or a grid.
Like most apps it's built
from standard UI components,
right off the shelf,
which makes it intuitive to use.
At first glance,
this may seem like a daunting task.
There are probably a lot of
pieces you're not familiar with.
But don't worry.
By the end of this class,
you'll have the confidence and
skill to create this app on your own.